guys welcome to my youtube channel
before i start i just want to remind you
like subscribe to this video especially
subscribe
because i'm trying to move out of my
parents house someday
anyways my mom's right here hey mom
and are you excited for our meeting
tonight
uh no not there's gonna be some
really big reveals that she doesn't know
about
um not the same thing we did last time
though
and there's gonna be there's gonna be
some shockers
but i think i think it's gonna go well
any final words help me figure out
what's for dinner
dad dad wait wait dad i'd like to
interview you really quick how do you
feel about the meeting
going in what meeting i told you the
family meeting
he's not going for a walk you're not
going to show up
i told you it's like between seven and
eight i meant it's not everything
right now so okay okay but we're waiting
on adam like just
don't leave before eight chaz how do you
feel about the family meeting
remember i told you meet adam oh yeah
i'm definitely going to the gym
okay well you know what the excitement
isn't what i was hoping
but that's okay there's going to be some
big reveals you won't even know it's
going to hit you
great i can't wait i said i'm very
open to the concept of a family meeting
okay
i can't wait to hear the big reveals
there's going to be lots of reveals
don't don't get too excited
i'm a little nervous for this
presentation but i know it'll bring the
family closer together
honestly
and i know that
there's going to be some shock there's
going to be some disbelief but i know
they're going to be happy for us
all right so me and adam did a thing
today
we did hannah and i got boarded up to
apply for jobs apply for jobs
oh great worst thing in the world can we
could we get a round of applause
what kind of job yeah starting off
we need to think about how are we going
to get employed we're both too broke
people living at home hannah not much
going for us
hannah a former employee of some company
no one can even say
she graduated immersed in 2018 like it's
been a minute it's been a while
and she quickly discovered fame is hard
and so i got cancelled this week
and now she's sick of living out oh me
too
we've got that in common so we have some
solutions for you
next next we have adam
so adam was formerly employed by
coaster medals which doesn't exist
anymore it went bankrupt this year
yeah he graduated in 2018
and he changes his major every six
months at least
so he won't have to graduate
and he likes living at home for the free
food he's a former pothead
however
current alcoholic hold on
this is good but no more no more no
more no more so then we went on the list
we were like we need possible jobs
possible jobs
and i were like all right what can we do
what what can we do
well we're both too driven i was like
i'm great at recruiting people to do
stuff
i'm gonna be a recruiter i'm creative
marketing and a great marketer
i'm an okay programmer engineering not
for me but maybe yeah
digital ads i think hannah could have
done i could do that
management and leadership opportunities
i think the two of us would succeed
yep and or self-employed self-employed
so we decided to look up some jobs this
is one of our first
i'm not a cat formerly essentially a
hobo
i didn't know what that was i don't know
either they're home
their entire job is to go do stuff for
very little amounts of money in one
small town in
third world countries their entire life
is one small area okay
that's great adam i like that are there
nice girls there
well for the most part really what i
don't see any women in these pictures
i mean cooking
pick one every other third is the girl
oh okay
okay depends on the night right
now i can't pronounce the word yeah we
don't know how to say words
the following job is very important this
is really good for me
right so i used to er i would earn tips
by performing i'm like a performer
basically i would be doing i would be
doing like dances you know what i mean
she'd
um and then i put together hairs you
know do my hair and makeup
it's all about performing and wait what
are you doing
and then i also would get to get
exercise
at work so i'd be skinny
here's your job education this is
blackjack
and i was thinking my stage name
could be daddy issues sorry dad
[Music]
okay and adam also was considering this
i also put an application in just to see
if they would like it just
you never know what the future can hold
oh and what happened well we'll see
we'll see
we applied today so we'll find out yup
now next did you really apply yeah why
not
did i stutter we had nothing better to
do
nothing better than you
what do you think we did all day
i was very busy man i was very busy
that way you were awake so early i
haven't slept in two days stop
asking questions all right what's next
what's next a model of recruiter
last one you're gonna finish it that's
new well this is awesome
we said we said the same thing this is
exercise yeah
it's like are you paying attention
our model recruiter see this is a very
high demand job
do you recognize the corner logo right
there
as a member of a growing team i'd have
to be very specific in my model
selection
yes a growing team i'd have to validate
personnel and make sure that
they aren't lying about who they are
validate personnel
i'd have to monitor broadcast social
media messaging and
creator miller and text yep i'd have to
perform other departmental duties as a
sign
you never know what that could be but
adam's quick on his feet
and now on the job location
now adam would be recruiting women this
isn't bad but luckily
he hasn't been doing that already
luckily adam has plenty of experiences
yeah thank you for pointing that out dad
thank you for pointing that out
now we have another one a sales person
no i have plenty of experience in this
role hannah was feeling
left out so she wanted to go back to her
former role yes yes but in a different
way
and that's different one you can make up
to 24k in them single month
it's amazing 24k you get to know them
sound good big time names and big-time
ballers very quickly
very quickly you can be a part of a
larger organization and it's easy to
apply
okay
now the great part about this is your
clients are
literally addicted to you yeah that
would probably be
so if you are successful than your last
job i
know i know thanks for thinking mom
oh thank god thank you for watching um
we're excited for our future
so what do you think about our career
path i should try many just to find out
you like the best
which do you think i should start with
um i don't know what'd you put is the
word how about an uber driver
i i'd say it was a politician i don't
know how to pronounce this word but i
think hannah would do well at it
yeah there's pros and cons of this job
the
the pro is i get exercise at work the
con
is that i have to spend like ten
thousand dollars
i have to spend ten thousand dollars on
a boob job no thanks
mom i'm not giving me the booze in the
family
i don't know what to tell you i
certainly didn't order you that way
you know what there's so much
opportunity i didn't know what to say
it kind of laid it out quite well i
thought i did a good job
[Music]
i think you should just start with one
and see how it goes
i think so too this is an awesome
presentation
thank you very much um
i think i came up with the best job
opportunity actually so adam how did you
think that went
i thought it went pretty well uh yeah
how about we just
we're still running i don't know what
that one is how do i put it into action
like
i don't know making money doing it i
like the idea well what do you start
with
we can start with we can we said why
would we make money when we can move no
no
we started the presentation with we're
ready to get a job
but not but not too far we're just ready
to start to have some extra spending
cash
but not like look at things like page
pull up the page just
we don't want to hold the page really
quick really quick i'm ready to keep
sitting on our asses all day just doing
better
yeah in your own place and your own
car insurance we can start a drug
kidnapping and being right there
no i don't trust feelings you could just
get them all done right at your
all right well thanks a lot for your
opportunities in life to
move forward i like that thank you i'm
glad we paid
highly for the education that you got
i've seen used it well
this is my favorite one was the
kidnapping rate
rates for uh i told them to take that
out of there like look at this
460. i told them i totally take care of
shocking really that many
years how many are from family members
though
600 missing uh people oh ellie looks so
cute in this she's the star of the show